ein tag essen wie in deutschland eine
interessante zweite folge von unserem
neuen format aber wenn man so darüber
nachdenkt eigentlich richtig cool wie
oft hat man es dass man sich wirklich
darauf besinnt wie ursprünglich wie
traditionell in deutschland gemessen
wurde und macht das einen ganzen tag
lang wir haben uns vorgenommen und nicht
nur das wir auch beim friseur deshalb
wundert euch nicht wenn ich gleich beim
frühstück um geschnittene haare habe es
gibt meist wirst du das geht es jetzt
erst eine anekdote es einmal pro woche
reise wird wir haben irgendwann
angefangen das bei uns im büro zu so
einer sache zu machen jeden dienstag
starten wir mit weißwurstfrühstück und
die jungs sind natürlich auch jetzt
gerade wieder hier und da sich das nicht
entgehen dazu trägt man alkoholfreies
weizen und ich weiß auch nicht irgendwie
ist das so ein geiles ritual und ich
finde es auch so krass lecker sind wir
einfach besser leben so hier perfekt ein
geschenk des weißen ganz ohne fehler
freust du dich dann darauf jetzt einen
tag lang nur deutsch zu essen sagt sie
ehrlich die deutsche küche geht manchmal
im europäischen vergleich ein bisschen
unter aber wir wären heute auch wieder
fest es gibt so viele geile deutsche
gerichte das ist wirklich wahr so und
natürlich dass auch relativ schwierig
für mich weil im rahmen von diesem
format möchte ich ja immer die kulturen
von gewissen ländern wirklich
authentisch näher bringen in deutschland
kann ich als erster an natürlich ganz
gut berichtet aber wie kochen das war
das was ab es ist super einfach einfach
wasser aufkochen ausmachen weißwürste
hinein eben durchziehen lassen geht's
noch mal im backofen warm machen fertig
und dann ist natürlich das wichtigste
wie man sie jetzt erzähle ich habe schon
angst vor den kommentaren ich glaube da
gibt es sehr viele starke meinungen
drüber aber jemand
erfolg sehr weil ich irgendwie verkaufen
wir warten erst mal dass das wasser
kocht und dann sehen wir uns recht so
das wasser kocht die machen aus neben
einfach gesagt du wirst du hier hinein
lassen jetzt 10 14 12 minuten ist alles
was man machen das ist wirklich
traumhaft einfaches frühstück und es ist
so geil abwechslungsreich weil ich kenne
wirklich kein frühstück was in diese
richtung geht sauer salzig herzhaft und
das wird noch diesen geilen brezen tag
weiß was drin deckel drauf war du machst
schleicht heute eigentlich schon richtig
was beim mittagessen marke mini um so
freunde es ist so weit traurig an wie
wunderschön sie gekommen sind gehen wir
hier ganz unkompliziert schnell gleich
mit den anderen zusammen erst mal aber
ich zeige euch natürlich der weiß was es
gibt natürlich verschiedenste
philosophien dazu ich schneide sie
einfach der länge nach auf zack zack
zack bumm nicht ganz durch und dann
verliere ich ohne die haut
durchzuschneiden noch mal und es ist
sehr schwierig weil dann kann man
einfach so die haut die wurst aus dazu
dann ein wenig süße senden
ich wünsche euch dass sie so bezeichnet
so wir machen uns schon immer viel
stress so die jungs die mit uns arbeiten
haben wir finden trotzdem jeden dienstag
zeit bis zu tun dazu macht 100 so ein
lauf für eine laugenbrezel
es ist so perfekt wie war sehr gespannt
wie viele leute wie böse sein werden
darüber wie ich dass es vielleicht auch
keiner das ding ist man kann ja auch
schrittweise ich so aussaugen und trifft
das mache ich nicht habe ich mir aber
das ist auch nicht ganz beispiels mache
ich finde ja immerhin auch aus
aschaffenburg das ist ja sehr frühes
bayern aber es ist bei uns direkt hinter
der grenze zu messen lassen auch nicht
vernachlässigen darf wenn man so ein
weizen dazu trinkt das hat jetzt gezeigt
[Musik]
wie viel ist das lag auch noch mal also
ist ein absolutes traumlos man hat
wirklich richtig power dann anfällig
also ich glaube das war's das frühstück
ausmacht ist ein bisschen die tradition
die wir jetzt bei uns einen bürgern
lassen haben jeden dienstag dass man
zusammen kommt dass man so flüssig das
eine besonderheit ist dabei bier oder
alkoholfreies bier zu trinken und wenn
man daran spaß hat dann ist es richtig
rein ich kann aber auch verstehen dass
es vielleicht ein bisschen abstoßend die
zum frühstücken und der leute werden
dann eine kleine pause brauchen aber wir
sehen unsere mittagessen bei dem hit mit
dem mittagessen wir wieder hier kochen
bevor es dann heute abend in ein feines
deutsches restaurant aber du hast kommen
wir da nicht vergessen ein zu kommen
zum glück habe ich ein paket von head of
rage bekommen und wir gucken einmal war
es und zwar lauter traditionelle
deutsche zutaten für kasseler mit
karamellisiertem suppengrün ist jetzt
natürlich kein rezept von großmutter
aber wie gesagt traditionelle deutsche
zutaten und genau das ist das ding bei
hello fresh die freundlicherweise dieses
video unterstützen sie probieren ein
bisschen abwechslung rein zu bringen so
das werdet ihr so nicht finden ihr
werdet auch die anderen sachen die es in
meiner helau fresh box noch mit dabei
waren also kam der sandwich oder tacos
werdet ihr wahrscheinlich in dieser
hoffnung auch nicht wenn ich aber genau
das finde ich cool und das ja das kunde
bei hello verschickte genauso viel wie
für zwei drei vier portionen braucht wir
legen jetzt los und machen uns zwei
portionen so als erstes müssen wir das
gemüse seien also wenn man diese rezept
karte da steht auf der rückseite drauf
wie man alles zubereitet wir müssen das
gemüse schneiden dann müssen wir stoppen
um kasseler anbraten danach das gemüse
das gemüse dann karamellisieren
währenddessen machen wir eine kleine so
ist fertig und muss nur noch anrichten
und das beste es ist in einem topf also
sehr entspannt für uns und wir haben
jetzt zum essen und zum ist so wir
schneiden also zuerst das problem ich
mal wieder so richtig stupides malen
nach zahlen von januar ist einfach
richtig nach dem sexakt in dünne
scheiben schneiden
ich meine wenn es am ende schmeckt ist
doch alles gleich obwohl so also wir
schneiden das jetzt hier einfach in
dünne scheiben das hilft auch dabei dass
man besser kanalisieren kann man den
feind schneidet jetzt das gleiche mit
der staudensellerie
möhren schälen ich mir ebenfalls
einhalten so schritt 1 abgabe geben uns
ein bisschen öl in die falle
hier raten jetzt gleich schön dass
taster drin anders auch ein bisschen was
kleben da in der falle von amrum und
danach kommt das gemüse
[Musik]
und
sodann kann aber schon unser gesamtes
grünbein
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt ein teelöffel zucker
und 150 milliliter wasser vor der geruch
direkt nach karamell welcher zucker ohne
wasser ist korrekt arbeiten wirklich
glaube gibt es das verträgt ackermann
man hört seine stimme nicht
explizit mit uns gehören dazu kommen wir
sind auch die gewürzmischung helau
muskat also muss karte würzmischung hier
würden wir ebenfalls herunter das
reduziert schon so wichtig wenn man das
nicht täte sascha kraus zusammen die
zuckersparte jeder zu hause hat macht
man einfach selbst ein also es war jetzt
kein päckchen hürde seither vermarktet
jetzt aufwand aber das ist ja sehr
schöne farben oder
außerdem drei sachen der bornet joghurt
sind meiner machen jetzt einen kleinen
tipp bekommen nämlich gleich mit auf den
teller lebens einfach alles in der
schlüssel hier vorne verquirlen wir
einfach alle damen tun das sind ja auch
geil alter wenn man so gerade so die
landesküche die man kennen wenn man auch
innerhalb dieser landesküche noch mal so
ein bisschen anfängt zu experimentieren
dafür neu kombiniert und da neue sachen
entdeckt
damit ist und eigentlich nur noch zeit
anzurichten wir nehmen jetzt die shop
wurde und menschen die unter das
suppengrün mal den fuß
nicht schön das aroma von allen genau
dafür länger satt
[Musik]
gesehen man kann natürlich trotzdem auch
selbst kreativ werden zb beim anrichten
kann das ganz natürlich auch ergänzen
mit zutaten jemand gehabt aber das ist
das grundrezept von hello frühstück ist
genau die richtige menge von
lebensmitteln nach hause geliefert um
genau die funktionen zu kochen auf die
du lust hast wenn ich cool ob wir das
ganze jetzt mal muss nämlich auch noch
schmecken sonst weiß nicht wieso ist
also ein auto dieser tipp konnte kraft
dafür dass sie nur drei zutaten sind der
täter wäre kein problem wir caster
natürlich auch noch mal dazu
wartet auf jeden fall den spot dieses
geile traditionell deutsche
so läuft wie seine person habe ich jetzt
auch essen eine wichtige eben von auch
ihr könnt mit dem kot hf max bis zu 80
euro auf die ersten vier boxen spannen
ein beispiel wenn ihr eine box bestellt
wie ich drei portionen für zwei personen
bezahlt er dafür mit meinem coach in der
ersten woche 15 euro sechs portionen
nach hause liefert 15 euro fällig durch
ein super den ich euch auch wirklich
nicht vorenthalten möchte deshalb haben
spaß damit probiert es aus und das ganze
ist auch wöchentlich kündbaren er ich
muss jetzt auch erstmal wieder ins bett
müssen also dann leute zeit das
abendessen ich habe mich so sehr darauf
gefreut ist ein extra die haare
geschnitten habe wir gehen in ein
traditionelles kölsches brauhaus wir
sind ja beim kreis darauf an
griechenmarkt und reingehen
[Musik]
zwei bier soll nämlich mich ich bring
euch schon mal wasser oder bier können
ist es ja auch so kriegt immer neue
station steht außer macht den deckel aus
kirchen
sowie sein ob diese sind ist jetzt so
einen tag lang das zu essen wie immer
das ding ist es überhaupt nicht mehr das
ist durch gar nicht immer ist das viel
mehr voll besonders finde ich so einen
tag bewusst nur deutsche öffentlichkeit
also ich feierte schmidtgal ich liebe es
auch andere glücklich sein leben aber
auch mal so die eigene ästhetische ihren
wir starten den haaren bin und mir da
merkt man einfach deutschen
schweinebraten mit
schwarzem etappen
schneiderhan
man merkt dass wir hier in köln sind mit
halve hahn brauhaus original davon wären
wir auf jeden fall etwas curry wurst
grünkohl sauerbraten bieten der himmel
un äd das ist auch sehr klassische ja
ich mag es auch wirklich gerne damit
stelle weil ja wir haben was gefunden
und zwar einmal hin und einmal die
gänsekeulen
dankeschön
das wird sich dem kölner häusern hat auf
jeden fall immer spaß mit dem kürbis
zunächst einmal lust
[Musik]
das soll schmecken
das erinnert mich gerade unnormal an
meine kindheit himmel und erde bluetooth
apfelkompott traffic gerät das
eigentlich so ein ding das jetzt in
irgendeinem hipster das waren absolute
pressetext das ist im gegensatz zu
die albaner auf jeden fall sehr froh
hier zu gewinnen ist das erste transfer
deutsches essen schon immer sehr fleisch
und auch vor allem sehr schreien lassen
kommt so schönes papier auch bei denen
bei uns
ganz oben ganz ganz klassisches mit
lösung rot-weißes ganzes ganz ganz
klassisch man
auch schwer hat schon mal eine ganz
probiert setzen ja ist das meine quellen
weiter machen schöneweide haben aber auf
jeden fall mal was ich sagte 'ich muss
bringt einfach schön saftig brauhäuser
mit auch mal vielmehr der focus aus
trinken aber hier können sich auch sehen
lassen erika wir weiter warten müssen
jetzt auf das man sehen uns leid
[Musik]
das war doch schön richtig
gastfreundlich leckeres essen gut
bürgerlich sondern es seien also das war
ein voller erfolg ab wir sehen uns
gleich im büro wieder weißwurstfrühstück
schupfnudeln mit kassler und köllges
brauhaus leute das war auf jeden fall
einen tag mit deutschem essen und ich
muss wirklich sagen es war
abwechslungsreicher als ich mir
vorgestellt hätte und es war auch
unfassbar lecker deshalb macht das gerne
mal nach und ganz besonders wichtig
schreibt in die kommentare welche küche
wer als nächstes machen sollen wir
können auch mal ganz exotisch gehen ich
freue mich auf eure kommentare und wir
sehen uns schauen
[Musik]